the Commerce Department has released its
monthly consumer spending report for the
month of March consumer spending drives
the US economy and is seen as a key
indicator of how deeply the current
coronavirus crisis is affecting everyday
Americans
personal consumption expenditures or all
the goods and services purchased in the
United States was about twelve and a
half trillion dollars in March down from
about thirteen and a half trillion
dollars from the previous month with
stores and restaurants being forced to
close in jobless claims at record highs
consumers are unsurprisingly spending
less money this consumer spending report
is released monthly and economists
investors analysts all pay a ton of
attention to it because of the huge role
that the spending has on the domestic
economy consumer spending makes up about
68 percent of GDP and the United States
this is a really wide-ranging figure
this represents everything from people
going to the mall to shop at stores to
buying groceries to getting haircuts
it's anything you spend your money on so
in March we saw businesses across the
country start to shut their doors and
social distancing measures were put in
place and people were staying home more
than they had you know maybe ever
so that puts a serious hamper on how
much money they are spending consumer
spending was at record highs a few
months ago driven in part by a decade of
wage growth and low unemployment but us
employees shed around 700,000 jobs in
March raising the unemployment rate to
four point four percent a number that's
expected to increase in April what we're
really seeing play out here is kind of
this domino effect that spending can
have on the entire economy so a lot of
people are left jobless they have less
money to spend that's less money that
they're putting into the pockets of
other people retail sales were down
eight point seven percent in March with
sales for clothing down as much as 50
percent from a year ago the US
government has tried to offset the
impact of this coronavirus downturn with
a stimulus package like we've never seen
before and the hope is that people who
may be left jobless
or whose income may have taken a hit
they you know they might be able to pay
their rent or they'll go out there and
they'll spend this money to potentially
stimulate the economy some analysts say
consumer spending can be a lagging
indicator of how the economy is doing
because it looks at spending from the
previous month
but it's growth almost always slows
heading into a recession if you look at
the last recession spending dipped
during the second half of 2008 consumer
spending is obviously a huge chunk of
the domestic economy but how much people
are spending also tells you how
confident they're feeling about their
current economic situation their current
jobs their future jobs a survey of
consumer sentiment plunged around 20
percent in early April the largest
monthly decline ever recorded there are
some corners of the economy where
consumers are still spending while
staying at home for example they're
paying for streaming services and buying
things online benefiting the stock
prices of companies like Netflix and
Amazon no one worried that a lot of
analysts and economists have right now
is that once businesses are reopened
whatever that might be that people won't
just bounce back and start spending at
the pace that they did previously
you know the worry is that the rebound
could be a little bit slower than what
money people are expecting right now